اهتمام وثيق تليه تليه كبرى العقول
العسكريه مشاهدينا في الصين للعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا فمنها نتعلم
الدروس
وتحول نقاط الضعف لمكان قوه
مشاهدينا الجيش الصيني ورغم كونه الاكبر
في العالم مع
خدمه نحو مليوني جندي بصفوفه الا انه لم
يتم اختباره الى حد كبير وكانت اخر حروبه
فاشله في فيتنام عام 79
وبمراقبه كل منعطف للحرب مشاهدينا استخلص
القاده الصينيون سبعه دروس من التجربه
الروسيه اخطاء تتجنبها الصين ان قررت غزو
تايوان الدرس الاول مشاهدينا يتمثل بايجاد
طرق لاسقاط شبكه ستار لينك للانترنت او
تعطيلها فهذه الشبكه مكنت القوات
الاوكرانيه من التواصل بشكل امن
واستخدمتها عسكريا بالسيطره على المسيرات
اما الدرس الثاني مشاهدينا فهو تعزيز قدره
الصين على الدفاع عن دباباتها ومدرعاتها
وسفنها الحربيه من الاف الاسلحه المتطوره
المحموله على الكتف بما فيها صواريخ
جافلين فيما قلل القاده من اهميه منظومه
رابطين نجاحها في اوكرانيا بامداد
المعلومات عبر اما رابع المكتسبات الصينيه
من تجربه روسيا فتتمثل بمهاجمه الذيل
اللوجستيه للدبابات الروسيه اي شاحنات
الوقود والذخيره على الصين مشاهدينا ايضا
الاستثمار اكثر في تطوير المسيرات وضمان
هيكل قياده موحد وتنسيق والاتصال مع قاده
ذوي رتب منخفضه في الميدان توقع عمليات
تخريبيه من داخل اراضيها كهجمات على
قافلات نقل الاسلحه والقوات واستخدام
تطبيق المراسله التليجرام لجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه من المدنيين اما اخر
الدروس واهمها وهي التكيف مع موجات من
العقوبات الاقتصاديه الغربيه والتحضر لرد
فعل عالمي سيتبع حتما اي هجوم صيني محتمل
على تايوان
[موسيقى]